peut-être professeurs des écoles en
classe de cm1 depuis cinq ans vous avez
reçu des coups de poing et des coups de
pieds par un élève de 10 ans qu'est ce
qui s'est passé parce que c'est vrai
qu'un élève de 10 ans éric nous ça nous
a extrêmement étonné parce que c'est pas
la première fois que ça vous arrive tu
sais effectivement un enfant de 10 on
peut se dire c'est quelqu'un
physiquement qui n'est pas puissant pour
autant quand on est face à un garçon qui
déploie une violences depuis de nombreux
mois
on est tout simplement un puissant on
sait pas quoi faire on n'a pas de
réponse alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
en fait c'est qu'est ce qu'elle est et
des lots contexte le contexte toussaint
en vérité j'ai demandé à sept enfants de
sortir de la classe il est pas une crise
comment dire des dévises accès de
violence qui devenait dangereux dans ses
camarades et au moment je lui demandais
de sortir la classe quand j'ai ouvert la
porte il a tout simplement profiter du
fait que j'avais le dos tourné pour me
donner des coups de poing des coups de
pied
c'est ça c'est assez incroyable je sais
qu'à la base vous désignez pourtant une
carrière de professeur de français au
collège et vous êtes devenu finalement
professeurs des écoles qu'est ce qui
vous a fait changer d'avis en fait alors
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on a vu dans le
sommaire le français qui va intéresser
les enfants du collège qui sont plus
âgés
physiquement on peut prendre le dessus
sur nous est clairement font comprendre
progresseurs que s'ils n'ont pas envie
d'écouter ils ne le feront pas d'accord
vous êtes dit avec des élèves voilà des
classes tout petit voilà je vais avoir
moins de problèmes et donc il s'est
passé cet événement voilà cette violence
avec cet enfant de 10 ans qu'est ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous
avez fait vous avez essayé de vous
défendre vous avez vous avez fait quoi
puisque comment on peut réagir face à un
fonds d'un enfant de 10 ans qui qui qui
vous attaquent la première réaction la
plus normale c'était de vouloir protéger
le visage tout simplement et ensuite de
toute façon c'est un enfant donc je ne
peux rien faire j'ai voilà juste essayé
de me protéger et un collègue été témoin
de la scène et du coup ils intervenus
aussitôt
est-ce que vous avez les parents ensuite
de sept élèves n'ont pas du tout pas du
tout ils sont venus s'excuser auprès de
vous absolument pas auprès d'eux
proviseur non plus du directeur d'école
rien du tout non les avez jamais vus et
qu'est ce que vous avez fait qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire en fait même quand ça
arrive
vous avez quand vous retournez vers qui
va faire quoi les inspecteurs d'académie
vers quoi oui exactement c'est ça on a
nos inspecteurs il ya ensuite les
inspecteurs d'académie donc nous on fait
des remontées des signalements vous avez
fait un signalement
oui on a eu un deuxième fait l'an
dernier malheureusement et 7 cas d'avis
qu'il est toujours dans votre classe
oui toujours oui et il n'a eu aucune
sanction
non elle est toujours dans la tasse
tranquille on n'avait pas convoqué ses
parents il ya eu une réunion
précédemment à l'agression avec les
parents oui mais après l'agression en
amérique une agression aucune saccade
et quand on sait que directeur d'école
ne réagissent pas là dessus ça vous
étonne pas autour de la noce c'est
incroyable comme si oui est-ce qu'il a
changé de comportement d'enfant il a
changé de comportement après quand il
est revenu ou pas du tout le problème
c'est que c'est très fréquemment et
c'est un enfant qui régit viol un nom
sur le moment et qui par la suite
présenté ses excuses et exprimé des
remords mais ça n'empêche pas que ça
arrive quotidiennement vous aviez
signalé à la hiérarchie d'établissement
ce qui s'était passé
oui alors en fait si rare exemple
pourquoi est ce que le directeur n'est
pas à rire venue voilà c'est ce que
j'allais en faites vous entendre que le
directeur n'est pas notre supérieur
hiérarchique
c'est un collègue et supérieur
hiérarchique c'est l'inspecteur est
est-ce qu'on s'interrogeait alors ce cas
pour excuser mais au contexte familial
un enfant de 10 ans qui est violence est
souvent un enfant qui est violente et à
la maison est-ce qu'on s'intéresse à
l'environnement est-ce qu'il a des
grands frères et grandes soeurs qui
peut-être le maltraite est ce qu il a
des parents qui sont qui abusent de lui
et ce qu'on s'intéressait ce versant là
parce que c'est pas pour l'excuser mais
un enfant de 10 ans ou même parfois de
cinq ans on voit des enfants de 5 ans
violent mais eux sont victimes de
violence et si le problème est là on
aura beau on aura la droite qui nous
dira mais qu'il est en prison c'est de
la racaille ce qu'on veut mais
finalement si vous intéresse pas au
contexte sociologique et économique
parfois
eh ben on n'aura pas la réponse ça vous
fait rigoler parce que je le trouve un
petit peu caricatural quand même on n'a
pas ça me fait pas rire en fait parce
que ça ça m'inquiète un peu toujours
parce que bon quand on catalogue les
gens comme ça qui me les gens de droite
vont réagir comme ça enfin non oui
recherché pourquoi cet enfant a frappé
c'est c'est une idée c'est une bonne
idée mais dire les gens de droite vont
mettre en prison
je pense que tu trouveras jamais tu pour
te dire
10 ou 15 reprises en raison allez on va
alors j'aurai pardon convienne sur lucie
sur votre cas vous dites que les parents
ne jouent pas leur rôle
ils font trop confiance à leurs enfants
oui je vais pas dire tous les parents en
l'occurrence le problème se présente
depuis deux ans maintenant et on n'a pas
leur action de la part des parents qui
ferme un petit peu les yeux sur la
violence de leurs enfants alors je ne
dis pas que les parents ce sont
principalement la cause du problème
en attendant on n'a pas de soutien de la
part des parents et on peut pas échanger
avec eux ce que vous avez pensé arrêter
non pas pour l'instant c'est un métier
qui vous plaît toujours
oui c'est un métier de passion je pense
comme nombre d'entre nous mais c'est
vrai qu'au vu de la tournure des
événements je me dis que c'est pas un
métier que je ferai jusqu'à la retraite
et comment alors regardant comment ont
réagi les les camarades de classe de
cette enfant en fait quand il vous a
agressé alors heureusement la porte
était fermée donc aucun enfant n'est
moins de l'accident